dernier volet il est consacré au mexique
l'invité de la foire philippe bru a fait
le tour du stand il nous le fait
découvrir par deux côtés sympathiques et
corsé la gastronomie et la musique
m
comme chaque année à la foire de caen
l'artisanat et la gastronomie sont
encore les deux temps forts
présenté par le pays invité à ce niveau
le mexique ne manque pas de richesse les
artisans poterie peinture et tissage
sont présents sans oublier la nourriture
avec un restaurant mexicain et de
multiples il ya pas mal de réussite et
quelquefois une petite réticence au
début parce que les gens s'imaginent que
c'est forcément très épicé ce qui n'est
pas ce qui prépare ses malka et certains
plats qui sont effectivement à pimenter
d'autres beaucoup moins
henin pour tous les goûts en fait on
peut manger par exemple pour combien
pour goûter certaines choses mexicaine
le visiteur peut manger comprend bien et
bien donc dans le restaurant les mêmes
avec le spectacle le menu est à 90
francs assurez vous si votre
porte-monnaie refuse ce restaurant à 90
francs vous pourrez toujours vous
rabattre sur l'attaqué ria le mexique
qui propose de découvrir les fameuses
tortillas ces galettes de maïs auquel on
ajoute de la viande de la purée de
haricots noirs ou encore toutes sortes
de sauce pimentée
cela donne comme sur ces images des
tacos cacahuètes tomates cacao il y en a
vraiment pour tous les goûts
mais si votre palais ne supporte pas le
piment les mariachis ce sont tout
proches ça pique beaucoup moins la
langue et la musique restent très douces
pour les oreilles
koné
les moteurs
là
tenez